hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round three of this
year's European Championship uh it's uh
Dennis cadrich of Montenegro versus
France and it's a really a wild game
it's basically an immortal tsukswang
game but not egg but not really because
uh one of the players also gets
checkmated very quickly so okay you
could argue that in in a Tuk tuang one
of the players will eventually get
checkmated but here it just happens a
very uh very quickly and you'll see what
I mean by this but it's uh absolutely
amazing how all of the pieces are
completely tied up uh so let's check it
out uh Cottage has the white pieces and
he opens with Ponte E4 we have Pawn to
C5 and mussar goes for the Sicilian
Defense Knight to C3 with D6 and now
Pawn to F4 uh Dennis goes for the Grand
Prix attack against the Sicilian G6 with
Knight to F3 Bishop to G7 and now Bishop
to B5 with check with Bishop to B5
Bishop to D7 and now usually yeah you
either a capture or maybe just Castle
but here we have Pawn to A4 which is a
fairly rare move Knight to C6 we have
castles and now comes the really rare
move now the position up until this
point has been reached before many many
times uh Magnus calls ahead against the
Nigeria vastly when you have against the
pile of pyramid head against vaitashek
Forester header against Gary Kasparov so
many times before in many notable games
we've seen this position but usually you
will see E6 or Knights to F6 or you will
see A6 here but here we ignite the D4
and this is very very rare only a few
games in the database with this move we
have D3 and now Pawn to E6 here Bishop
captures on B5 and Knight H6 are known
move but after Pawn to E6 we have a
completely new game uh so let's uh see
how it continues we have Ponte E5
already slightly unpleasant as you do
have to deal with your D6 spawn hanging
so Knight captures on B5 as you did put
your knight on D4 a captures and now
Pawn to D5 live musara says thank you
for for the extra space I can grab in
the center we have Pawn to D4 and now
Pawn to B6 with Bishop to E3 and now
Queen to C8 uh Rook the A6 not allowing
black to advance the pawn to A5 and
preparing to maybe double up or even
triple up on the a file uh Pawn to C4
and now Queen to A1 we have Queen to C7
uh and it now comes Bishop to F2 now
probably uh Dennis doesn't want the
bishop uh to to be a Target on E3 uh but
also uh once you see what he's preparing
it also makes sense for the bishop to
cover the E1 Square as you'll see Knight
the E7 the Knight might be useful on uh
CH the the guard the A7 pawn queen to A3
preparing for Rook to A1 and now Bishop
the C8 chasing away The Rook Rook the A4
and now we have Bishop to fa threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries here and
you could actually play this like you
could play Rook day one and now black
doesn't really have a good Discovery if
Knight the C6 you just move the queen
queen back to A2 and if Knight to A5
okay now the Knight prevents you from
attacking A7 but you're gonna play
Bishop P1 you're gonna move the Knight
you're gonna capture on A5 So eventually
you will break through but okay here uh
Dennis goes for an even stronger idea
and that is Pawn to B4 and now look at
this C capture some B3 C captures and
Bishop to D7 going after the at the B5
Pawn uh the problem is uh here you have
to really calculate what happens if you
take the free Knight and if the Knight
is free we don't know that uh but um
yeah in the game it wasn't played in the
game Bishop to D7 was played I will just
show what happens uh because it's it
requires quite a lot of calculation and
probably why uh uh mustard didn't go for
it Rook the C1 attacks the Queen Once
you move the queen and queen to D3 is
the only Square you have now you play
Rook captures on A7 and after Rook
captures Queen captures you play Bishop
to H6 this is the star move you have to
find in order to claim any sort of
Advantage maybe in this position Rook to
C7 goes after the Knight now you just
castle and you give up the night Rook
captures and E7 you give back the piece
but now click the captures on F4 and you
are back in the game and most likely uh
even better this is now a weakness this
is a weakness your your pieces are
excellent okay the light score Bishop is
a bit weird but you can't have
everything once you eliminate these
pawns and light squares maybe the bishop
can come back into the game however in
the game uh Bishop to D7 was played uh
Jill did not want to go after this um uh
Knight on C3 and now Rook the C1 and now
it's very very hard for black to play
this queen to B7 we have Queen to A2 and
now Bishop to G7 hoping that Castle but
just Rook to A1 threatening Rook
captures an A7 so Queen to C7 now
definitely threatening to pick up the
Knight and Bishop to E1 defending the
Knight we have Knight the C8 now
guarding the A7 pawn and the queen to A3
stopping Castle so Bishop f8 attacks the
queen queen back to C1 and now Bishop to
E7 but now Rook 4 to A2 inviting black
the castle but if black castles uh it's
it's pretty much resigns if you Castle
F5 and that's it doesn't matter G
captures or ecaptors you're gonna play
Queen to H6 and once the Knight comes to
G5 it's all over it the way you do it is
of of course Bishop D2 to G5 you
challenge the bishop and then the Knight
comes the at the G5 so after this Rook
for the E2 we have Queen the B7 and now
Queen to E3 we have Pawn to H6 now comes
Queen to D3 and now King the f8 going
for uh artificial castling here H3 King
to G7 and now the G4 we have fun to H5
Rook to G2 now aligning The Rook nicely
with the King on the G file King back to
f8 and now Bishop to D2 We have Bishop
to d8 and now Knight to D1
uh age captures on G4 H captors and now
Rook the H3 so black manages to activate
his Rook uh but you'll see uh it's not
all that impressive King to F2 and now
Bishop to E8 here you could also go for
Bishop to H4 but then you uh well you
pretty much lock your Rook here on H3
King G1 again there's nothing here for
black so after King F2 Bishop the E8 was
played and now look at Black's pieces
this is this is no way to play there's
no way to play chess a knight to C3
Queen to E7 and now uh Pawn to G5 you
completely keep the black queen out of
the game okay the black queen still has
access to B4 but do you really want your
queen on B4 there's nothing else black
in place so he does go for Queen to B4
now white could go for some nasty
discoveries here but uh that's not even
the strongest move forward look at this
Rook H2 uh Rook captures with check
Knight captures and now Queen captures
on B3 white even gives up a pawn uh but
now Knight to G4 and there's no move
black can make in this position there
there is no move none of the pieces can
act enter the game and the only move you
can make
otherwise you're just waiting for the
Knight to come to F6 is Queen to C4 so
he offers a queen trade uh you could
maybe postpone this go for Knight E7
maybe try to bring the Rook into the
game uh but look at this Knight to F6
and now if Rook to C8 you just play in
the queen to H3 how do you stop this
Checkmate Queen H uh
uh six will be Checkmate so Knight the
G8 let's say you do this now comes Queen
to a trade now it's written uh Queen
characters Knight here and if Bishop
captures you just play G capture so now
you cover both the the G7 and D7 squares
and if Bishop captures on B5 you okay uh
create some uh breathing room for the
king queen G7 check King yeah now you
take the Knight King goes here you take
the opponent F7 King to C6 and now even
Rook captures an A7 and there's no
defense Queen captures and E6 is
Checkmate on the next move regardless of
what black plays so uh that's why you
really don't have a move here Queen to
C4 was played uh but the queen trade um
that doesn't help black in any way so
Queen captures D captures now Rook to H1
going after that h8 square King to E7
King to G7 isn't much better than just
Knight to F6 and then uh Rook Rook to H7
so nothing happening there now comes
Knight to F6 Bishop to C7 and here we
have Knight C to E4 and he was in this
position on move 44 that uh Jean musar
resigned the game
uh as there is nothing more to be done
here uh the problem is now that the
knight move that there is no defense
against Bishop to B4 whatever you play
Bishop to B for just ends the game even
if you try to give your king some
squares uh Bishop B for check and you
cannot defend King to d8 Rook date check
Bishop T8 and now uh well Rook cap
percentage will be Checkmate or if you
maybe try to play Pawn to A5 which makes
sense you
uh cover the B4 Square uh just B
captures an A6 Alpha Song and again
there is no more you can make everything
is exactly the same you're gonna have to
give up a piece or something just to be
able to get back into the game because
if you capture then it's a very similar
Checkmate Rook to h8 First going after
the bishop and once you move the bishop
then of course Bishop to B for check is
a game over Bishop to D6 you have to put
something in between because the King
has no squares Bishop captures uh Knight
captures and D6 and now a spectacular e
captures and D6 would have been
Checkmate but of course none of this was
uh happened over the board as uh on move
44 jumusar resigned the game uh there's
nothing more to be done here but yeah I
mean look at this position uh very I
mean you will not see this especially in
the game between uh such strong players
are being almost a 2700 player uh this
is in absolute positional Masterpiece by
by Dennis kadrich make no make no
mistakes there uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it very very
nicely done it's really a modern
Immortal Tuk Swang I would like to thank
funky monk ravishing reptiles YouTube
sakanka traveling tour safaris Jordan
Smith and uh Rajan for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the European
championship and everything else that's
happening in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day